goodbye mr nice guy that's the focus of
tonight's angle
so old joe called a lid early this
morning meaning
he's not making any public appearances
until the debate
on thursday night but come on it doesn't
really matter
there's simply no enthusiasm anyway for
biden out there
well unless you call this a groundswell
my name's joe biden i'm a car guy
and i got a 67 corvette this good wood
green that's a 60
that's not a 67 that's a 427
that thing gets up and goes anyway
choir you must be freezing freezing to
death
oh my god to prop him up
uh to create a veneer of energy well his
big donors
had to fund one of the greatest
propaganda campaigns in human history
and of course after being called out and
exposed by president trump as fake news
the dominant media was happy to oblige
by amplifying the campaign's pitch
really the only one that they have
which is that biden if you elect him
he's gonna get us back to normal after
all he's so nice
normalcy that seems to really be a big
part of the pitch the joe biden is
somebody
who who will allow the country to return
to normalcy
let's get back to normal steady the ship
this is a decency check on this
president joe biden presents
a plan to get to the calm
the calm the dignified
old grandfather chasing around his
grandkids
all over the yard boy do they think that
you're
stupid or what it's all being presented
and it's all being framed this way to
throw you off the scent
of what's really to come punishment
those running the joe show have always
hated middle america
that's why he was their perfect
candidate kind of a trojan
horse from the old slightly more
moderate party to push
through the new far more radical
policies
the marketing of biden as this nice
normal guy
was funded and promoted by some of the
most
ruthless the richest people in business
the media
and entertainment and once they get past
the election
it's payback time former labor secretary
robert reich and
other liberals are pushing for something
called a truth and reconciliation
commission
when this nightmare is over it would
erase trump's lies
comfort those who have been harmed by
his hatefulness and name
every official politician executive and
media mogul whose greed and cowardice
enabled this catastrophe
well the more recent inspiration for all
of this goes back to
the post-apartheid era in south africa
in other words
if you voted for or ever supported trump
you're a little better than the same
people who threw nelson mandela in
prison
their pre-election intimidation squads
have also been at hard at work in recent
days
check what uh check out what happened at
a free speech rally
in san francisco
well the handiwork against the
african-american
organizer was a messed up
you know front teeth um beat him in the
face
these are all the nice people supporting
joe
now biden is as oh well i think he's
he he he's sold you know he's sold about
as this guy who cares about the kids as
his teacher union allies fight to keep
those kids locked in virtual learning
that is a real world including when a
student
has a trump flag in the background
during one of those hideous zoom classes
seventeen-year-old anthony ribeiro says
he logged into chemistry class last week
from home
when what's behind him quickly became a
problem
his chemistry teacher asked him to
remove his trump flag
he said if you're not going to take it
down it's unacceptable and
i'm going to have to ask you to leave
the classroom today and at that point i
wave goodbye
ribeiro says it happened a second time
in a different class the next day
he says he took the flag down that time
worrying
it may start to affect his grades
a smart kid these are truly awful people
they're the so-called champions of
diversity
who want to cancel you frighten you
and even scare your children from
holding different views
of course on policy biden will oversee
an unending series of these types of
punishments but a lot worse
they intend to pack the courts make dc
estate
raise your taxes outlaw your guns flood
the country with illegal immigrants
just to name a few moves and of course
using kovit
as cover they'll institute draconian
lockdowns and other rules nationwide
and that will end up throwing millions
out of work all so they can reset
things here in the united states and
take power back for themselves
so under joe biden this isn't going to
be a government of
buy-in for the people no way
it's going to be a government of by and
for the people
who behave who don't rock the boat
who don't question our trade policy our
health care policy
government-funded abortions our military
expenditures overseas
and our open borders oh by the way if
you
gather to protest the coming lockdowns
that destroy your business
they'll punish you as well they might
even put you in jail
the biden puppeteers want the entire
country
to be like new york and california they
have the people in those states so well
trained
they didn't protest in any large numbers
even after all those people died
needlessly in retirement homes
after all those rolling blackouts
the billionaires levitating biden to
election day and the elites in the
united states media
they always viewed trump's america first
movement
as sort of a peasants revolt even though
it was run by a billionaire trump
and these titans of wall street and
silicon valley
they certainly don't want to have to
raise this much money every four years
the punishments both carried out and
threatened
are also designed to scare off any other
rich guy or gal from ever trying to do
what trump tried again
no other first family has endured what
the trump family has
all the lies the insinuation the
accusations
and the defamation how dare they enable
a man
who ran on exposing and reversing the
failed policies of not just the
democrats like obama
and the clintons but the bushes as well
how dare all of you for enabling that
and the closer we get to the election we
will hear a lot
from their allies like something i heard
today congressman francis rooney from
the old gop
establishment he's a retired congressman
who was invited on cnn
to throw shade at the president two
weeks before the election
has it been worth it for the judges and
the tax cuts
that's a really good question when you
look at the the
undermining of our base and the threats
to
to our future and you look at some of
the uh
things that have happened a lot of scar
tissue there and i don't know what we're
going to do going forward
thank you so much and thanks for your
decency as always
the question by the way was was it worth
it electing trump
and he says that's a good question what
and and the decency
how exactly did trump undermine the base
congressman rooney who is retiring
thankfully
before trump the gop hadn't won a
presidential election since 2004
he brought back the blue-collar voters
and now he's bringing in latinos too
the scar tissue congressman is what
the bush has left us they want us to
embrace
in the end a false sense of decency
today with biden
a fake dignity being peddled by a man
who despite his grandpa joe act
is still just nasty joe from scranton
when he's
i know exposed ask it i have no response
it's another smear campaign
right up your alleys they're the
questions you always have wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait you're getting
nervous man calm down
it's okay you're a damn liar man that's
not true
look here's the deal you're too old to
go for it
total fraud the normancy normalcy that
the
left craves i'll tell you what normal is
to them
it's when you're under their heel you're
taxed to death you're told where you're
going to get your health care
and one where well your speech is
stifled along with your religious
practice
if that's the kind of decency and if
that's the kind of return to normalcy
that you crave
yeah biden is definitely your candidate